[MUSIC PLAYING]
[PHONE RINGING]
ODED BEN DOV: Hey, Giora.
GIORA LIVNE: Hey, Oded.
How are you?
ODED BEN DOV: I'm
good, I'm good.
I'm actually headed
to your place now.
The team is joining
us for lunch later,
and we want to show you
this cool new feature.
I think you'll love it.
GIORA LIVNE: I'm waiting.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ODED BEN DOV: I started
Sesame around five years ago.
I didn't know I was
headed that way.
And I got on TV to
demonstrate a game
I developed that was
controlled using head gestures.
You move your head around,
and you chase this character.
The day after, I
get a phone call.
And the guy on the
line says, hi, I
can't move my hands or legs.
Can you make me a
smartphone I could use?
GIORA LIVNE: He
came, looked at me,
and said, well, I
have a new company.
I am not ready for changes now.
I told him that this
will be much better idea
to do good for the whole world.
And he was convinced.
ODED BEN DOV: It really
put a new perspective
on what technology
can accomplish
and how we can change lives.
And the Android operating
system's open nature
really allowed me to
innovate beyond what
I could imagine at first.
GIORA LIVNE: Ah, the first time
I used that, it was like magic.
I almost jumped from the chair.
ODED BEN DOV: So you
say, "open sesame."
GIORA LIVNE: Open sesame.
ODED BEN DOV: That's
how the phone opens on.
And from that point on, it
allows for operation of any app
by using only head movements.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Long time been asked
for a selfie feature.
I think it would be fun.
[CAMERA CLICKING]
[CHEERING]
SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE]
ODED BEN DOV: It's not
a standard company.
You have days when you're
crying from happiness,
because you really, really
touched the person's life.
With the app now
being on Google Play,
anyone can download
it around the world,
and we're seeing that.
One of our greatest
users is Alex Friedman.
I met him on social
circles, and at the time,
he was just starting a
campaign to raise awareness
around disabilities in Israel.
And he uses Sesame remarkably.
SPEAKER 2: It's fun, because we
can communicate all day long.
ALEX FRIEDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
ODED BEN DOV: Google Play
Console gives us a lot of tools
to care for our users better.
We see what's working
right and what's not.
Through the ratings
and reviews, we
can actually be in
touch with users
and take benefits from
all the great stuff
the Play Store offers.
I think the biggest
takeaway from Sesame
is the lives you touch.
Every successful user
is not just a number.
It's a whole life.
It's a whole story.
And we take those with us,
and those propel us forward
to keep doing what we do.
[MUSIC PLAYING]